nous allons vous donner notre confiance
elle sera exigeante et impatiente car
les Européens
mais vous avez des atouts une grande
expérience une conviction européenne qui
n'a jamais faibli et une vraie
légitimité politique mais il vous faudra
aussi du caractère et du courage pour
faire de l'Europe un espace où puisse se
former une volonté politique c'est ça
l'enjeu cela demande une vision qui fait
trop souvent défaut au chef d'État et
gouvernement la vision d'une Europe qui
s'occupe enfin des grandes questions qui
se décident à peser dans le monde à
défendre ses intérêts et agir pour son
développement économique et social et
cela demandera aussi vous en avez parlé
une nouvelle pratique institutionnelle
un retour à la méthode communautaire
avec une commission qui je l'espère j'en
suis sûr reprendra enfin tout son droit
d'initiative monsieur le Président comme
vous nous voulons que l'Europe réussisse
c'est tout le sens de la confiance que
nous allons vous accorder je vous
remercie